[Musique]
bonjour à tous et oui nous sommes de
retour c'est un plaisir de vous
retrouver dans point de vue c'est de
l'occasion évidemment de vous souhaiter
chers internautes une très belle année
2021 vous me direz ça peut difficilement
être pire que la précédente pour cette
première émission
nous avons mobilisé peut-être les deux
meilleurs on pourrait presque dire ça
tous les jours mais quand même là c'est
vrai et céistes observateurs de la vie
politique bonsoir nicolas baverez
bonsoir vous êtes et céistes avocat vous
aussi vous avez fait votre entrée dans
le figaro ce matin avec votre chronique
hebdomadaire que vous consacrez à
l'allemagne et à rôle qu'elle a tenu
dans la présidence européenne qu'elle a
exercé au second semestre 2020 vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres mais c'est votre
dernier livre de l' alerte democratico
édition de l'observatoire bonsoir
alexandre ii vecchio vous êtes le
responsable des pages débats du figaro
magazine c'est très important
vous êtes aussi en charge du figaro vox
est votre dernier livre recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste a été publié aux
éditions du cerf
je propose de commencer évidemment par
ce que certains appellent le fiasco de
la campagne de vaccination française
nous avons pris beaucoup de retard sur
presque tout le monde alors il est d
usage depuis quelques jours de tomber
sur le dos du gouvernement
nous on a choisi de vous poser une autre
question et si c'était la faute des
français parce que finalement si le
gouvernement prend autant de précautions
pour les vaccins notamment pour
recueillir le consentement des personnes
âgées dans les ehpad c'est peut-être
parce que les français ils sont en
situation de défiance très forte
regarder ce sondage
il a été réalisé par au doxa pour le
figaro et france info une grande
majorité de français 58% ne souhaite pas
pour l'instant se faire vacciner alors
qu'ils responsable de cette défiance est
ce que c'est le tempérament français ou
est ce que c'est le gouvernement qui n'a
pas fait suffisamment de pédagogie c'est
plutôt le point de vue de chloé mora est
les politologues et elle était ce matin
chez nos confrères d'europe 1 pourquoi
est ce que cette défiance existe à cause
du discrédit de la parole publique
et à cause du discrédit des autorités
donc la solution les dans la
transparence elle est dans l'honnêteté
elle est dans la capacité à reconnaître
ses erreurs aussi
nicolas baverez on dit souvent qu'on ne
peut pas faire le bonheur des peuples
malgré eux
est-ce que de la même façon si les
français sont si réticents à se faire
vacciner n'est pas normal que le
gouvernement prenne son temps que ce que
vous avez dit rond
enfin c'est un nouveau fiasco et la
france est la risée du monde
on a raté on n'a pas réussi à anticiper
cette épidémie il ya eu un ratage
monumental sur les masques on a raté le
déconfinement ratage sur les tests on
n'a pas réussi à isoler les malades pour
éviter la propagation du virus
et maintenant on est en train de rater
la vaccination et ça ça a des
conséquences absolument dramatiques des
conséquences pour la santé puisque on
est quand même déjà à 65 milles morts et
plus il faut jamais oublier que plus on
retarde le vaccin et plus on va
accumuler les morts et puis c'est
dramatique pour l'économie je rappelle
que ça nous coûte un milliard par jour
et que pour l'instant on a des gens qui
nous explique que ce milliard par jour
eh bien il est compensé par la dette
publique qui va tout payer mais en fait
la dette publique que c'est nous tous
donc c'est eux c'est absolument inouïe
ce qui se passe on a cinq cent mille
doses de vaccins disponibles et on a
réussi un administré moins de 500 contre
je le rappelle un million pour les
britanniques 4 millions pour les
américains et 200 milles pour les pour
les allemands donc c'est incroyable ce
qui est incroyable aussi c'est la
répétition ce qui était dit elle la
répétition des erreurs parce qu on a
toujours la même structure et des
décisions qui sont autoritaires opaque
prise d'en haut qui ne consultent jamais
ni les élus ni la société civile un
mépris complet pour l'opérationnel
c'est à dire qu'on ne se préoccupe
jamais des problèmes d'exécution et des
problèmes de logistique
on fait de la communication et on ne
fait pas de l'action donc c'est un état
si vous voulez on a un état qui
aujourd'hui est encore capable de
dépenser de l'argent de manière
complètement inconsidérés et dans le
vide puisque là on a acheté 500 milles
vaccins qu'on n'est même pas capable de
utiliser on est capable de dépenser mais
on n'est plus capable de faire ce que
doit faire absolument un état qui est
protéger et pour protéger il faut être
capable de décider donc aujourd'hui il
faut être très clair si la priorité
c'est de vacciner les gens dans les
ehpad et bien il faut les vacciner il
faut pas les vaccinés en leur demandant
d'aller faire de consultation médicale
est quasiment de passer devant un
notaire pour faire leur testament avant
de recevoir un vaccin qui est censé leur
leur sauver la vie
mais donc la france est vraiment devenu
le pays du but alexandre de vécu comme
tout le monde tombe du gouvernement j'ai
envie de les défendre
imaginez que on ait commencé la campagne
plus massivement et puis qu'ils aient eu
des effets secondaires
l'opinion se serait retournée est ce que
cette prudence quand même vous pouvez
pas la comprendre
suite désolé je vais encore contourner
l'intitulé de du thème du débat qui me
paraît être voué un peu aux idiots
utiles du dieu du gouvernement parce
qu'en réalité le gouvernement comme
d'habitude se défausse sur les
françaises certes 58 pour sont deux
personnes qui sont attentistes ou pour
une party hostile au vaccin mais il ya
tout de même 40% de personnes qui
veulent bien être vaccinés ça fait des
millions voire même des dizaines de
millions comme en sont peut-être par là
donc là de toute évidence qu'on a un
problème de logistique
à nouveau c'est pas la peine de faire
passer ça pour une stratégie pour
amadouer les français pourraient après
où il faut essayer d'expliquer le
pourquoi de ce problème de logistique je
pense qu'il ya il ya deux pistes la
première c'est le principe peut-être de
précaution on dit que voilà on recueille
lentement le consentement des français
mais en réalité on le fait aussi parce
que les politiques les administratifs
etc se protège et de la sorte il
participe à la défiance générale parce
que s'ils ont aussi besoin de se
protéger c'est que peut-être ils ne sont
pas sûrs de leur coup donc ça c'est une
première une première raison est la
deuxième c'est sans doute encore une
fois problèmes bureaucratiques français
une technocratie qui a coupé dans les
dépenses qu'ils pouvaient être utiles
les soignants notamment parce qu'il vous
faut pour vacciner et qui au moment de
mettre en place une logistique pour
déployer le vaccin est bien failli de
nouveau totalement comme cela est le cas
depuis le début de cette crise nous l'a
rappelé avec les masques ensuite avec
les tests donc voilà le scandale au
scandale il est là alors pour avoir un
point quand même de désaccords avec
nicolas baverez zhu essayer de prolonger
un peu le débat ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on constate tout de même même
si les autres pays européens font bien
mieux que nous dans l'ensemble que les
pays qui ont été
les plus souples les les plus efficaces
et ceux dont nicolas barreuse disait pis
que pont il disait qu'il allait très mal
géré la crise on voit bien que là pour
le coup donald trump je pense à trump
aux états unis je pense au royaume uni
qui est très en avance et même à
netanyahou en israël donc les populistes
normes pas voilà ne font pas tout mal on
peut discuter d'ailleurs de la stratégie
du vaccin peut-être qu'il lui fallait
une autre moi je suis pas spécialement
propres au vaccin mais on aurait
peut-être pu faire une stratégie du soin
mais ça on l'a on l'a écartée c'est le
gouvernement français qui l'a écarté à
partir du moment où j'ai choisi la
stratégie du vaccin et bien il faut
donner l'effet de souffle pour ça
fonctionne et mettre en place la
logistique pour ça fonctionne oui je
peux compléter l'interpellation
d'alexandre nicolas baverez on connaît
votre votre votre tropisme européen mais
même les allemands disent que l'europe
elle nous retarde plutôt qu'autre chose
dans cette affaire alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu des messages à dire le
problème français n'est pas là c'est
vrai qu'on a eu un certain retard sur
l'homologation
mais précisément j'allais dire le fait
de prendre du temps sur l'homologation
ça veut dire que ensuite on est vraiment
sûr du produit et donc c'est là où
normalement ça devrait être compensée
par une note une fois qu'on a homologué
le produit on devrait être capable pour
le coup de le déployer extrêmement vite
or là on accumule les retards les
britanniques c'est vrai que les
britanniques font un choix qui pour le
coup on peut quand même être questionné
puisque eux ont fait le choix d'aller
très vite plutôt sur une première
injection l'on possède a priori n'en
faut donc ça veut dire qu'avec une seule
injection
on protège les gens à 50 60 % ce qui est
quand même
normalement insuffisant pour un vaccin
et ils misent sur l'effet de masse pour
avoir le plus vite possible atteint 60%
de la population ce qui permettrait
d'améliorer les choses et si vous voulez
je voudrais qu'on en revienne aux choses
de très bon sens nous sommes en face
d'une maladie
contre laquelle on n'a pas de traitement
une maladie qui a bloqué quand même
l'ensemble de la vie nationale et qui a
créé des dommages sur la santé sur
l'état psychique du pays sur des
secteurs entiers de l'économie
gigantesque il se trouve que on n'a pas
de traitement mais maintenant on a un
vaccin donc la chose de bon sens c'est
de se dire qu'une fois qu'on a le vaccin
l'idée c'est d'aller le plus vite
possible et de ne pas organiser un
concours de lenteur avec en alignant les
problèmes bureaucratiques et les
américains ont trouvé par exemple on
parlait des problèmes de logistique les
américains ont confié la logistique
un militaire parce que c'est des
spécialistes de la alors le paradoxe de
la france c'est qu'on fait tous avec un
conseil de défense sanitaire qui n'a
rien à voir avec une épidémie mais qu'en
revanche la logistique on est incapable
de la coin de la confier à des gens dont
c'est le don dont c'est le métier grâce
est il qu'on n'arrive pas à retenir des
leçons parce que on a vu la même chose
maman des basques où je me souviens très
bien des acteurs de la grande
distribution 10 ans laissez nous faire
nous on sait où trouver les masses
exemple commerce avec la chine c'est la
journée où vous mais c'est là où vous
nous rejoignez c'est que on peut pas
dire que cette structure montrent que
c'est pas le problème des français les
français si on leur avait dit on n'a pas
de masque débrouillez vous pour faire
des masques
ils on a fait comme en afrique il aurait
bricoler des masques mais c'était mieux
en faire
oui mais c'était mieux que de ne pas en
avoir mais sauf qu'on a eu on ne leur a
jamais dit évidemment ça le vaccin ça ne
se bricole pas on est bien d'accord mais
sans doute aujourd'hui est ce qu on
devrait sûrement faire beaucoup plus
appel au secteur privé
il ya deux il ya deux types d'acteurs
qui s'affairent la logistique c'est soit
les militaires soit le monde du privé se
trouve que l'administration allait faire
démonstration qu'elle ne savait pas
faire donc choisi son mais faisons appel
faisant appel aux compétences et surtout
voyez il faut complètement renverser la
logique c'est à dire qu'il faut arrêter
avec ce concours de précaution de il
faut se dire que maintenant si vous
voulez le la france en prenant le retard
sur le vaccin
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de ce n'est
pas seulement le train du vaccin qu'on
est en train de rater le train de la
reprise
pourquoi parce que ce qu'on disait tant
que l'épidémie elle est là pour durer
on aura sûrement pas de traitement dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
donc si on rate la vaccination ça veut
dire que l'économie ne peut pas repartir
et elle va repartir chez les autres
étaient et elysée et très vite donc on
est vraiment en train d'infliger à ce
pays qui est déjà au bord de la rupture
une double peine sanitaires et
économiques mais maintenant il faut
quand même dire que maintenant c'est
vraiment insupportable et c'est pas et
c'est insupportable aussi qu' aucune
sanction contre les gens qui ont raté
successivement les masques les tests
isolement et maintenant le vaccin ça
fait trop et je vous repasse à parle
tout de suite un accent de partager
votre sévérité arrêtons de culpabiliser
les français nous décrit sur 78 sur
lefigaro.fr donc c'est ça ça n'est pas
de leur faute
nicole 06 qui revient effectivement sur
les derniers psychodrames dégel des
tests des masques pourquoi le
gouvernement ne fait pas de campagne de
communication pour répondre aux
questions que nous nous posons
s'interroge également christophe 78
babineau qui est de retour à qui on
souhaite de bonnes années 2000 21 kg dit
oui le rythme de la campagne vaccinale
est injustifiable
cette consultation est absurde et puis
sich toujours sur lefigaro.fr ne
comprends pas cette histoire de
consentement on va voir son médecin dit
il ils nous conseillent et basta
alexandre je voudrais juste vous faire
réagir sur la dernière initiative en
date du gouvernement qui est de mettre
en place un collectif de citoyens je
sens que ça va plus ça va encore être
terrible pour les malheureux qui nous
gouvernent ce collectif de citoyens
tirés au sort pour associer plus
largement la population à la campagne de
vaccination est ce que c'est une bonne
idée je m'empresse de vous dire que les
internautes sont plutôt sévères et c'est
un doux euphémisme puisque c'est la
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr 86 % de
nos internautes que l'on interroge
depuis ce matin considère que c'est pas
une bonne idée et vous n'ont cessé
complètement grotesque pour perdre
encore un peu plus de thon je pense que
c'est s'est pas fait en plus je les dis
arrêtons de raconter n'importe quoi on a
un problème logistique on n'a pas
problème de consentement d'ailleurs rien
n'empêche de faire une bonne campagne de
communication continuer à faire de la
pédagogie tout en déployant le vaccin je
le répète pour les 40% des français qui
le souhaitent ça doit faire à la louche
25 millions de français
donc non cette histoire de démocratie
participative et grotesque en plus
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ces citoyens
ils vont vraiment donner des pots celle
de logistique pour expliquer aux
médecins comme on vaccine comme on
stocke les vaccins comme on les reçoit
enfin ça me paraît ça me paraît
extrêmement surprenants bon ça dit des
choses sur la crise de la démocratie et
moi je pense qu'il faut effectivement
régénérer la démocratie implique est
beaucoup plus le citoyen mais en termes
de démocratie participative je connais
rien de mieux que le référendum est sur
des questions sur lesquelles ils peuvent
se prononcer et qui les intéressent qui
équipe qui plus est ça me paraît mieux
qu effectivement cette histoire de
tirage au sort qui en plus ne repose sur
rien en démocratie c'est c'est la
souveraineté populaire donc c'est la
majorité qui est censée décider avec
bien sûr des contre pouvoirs
mais là des citoyens tirés au sort très
peu enfin quelle légitimité y iso ça
montre que c'est extrêmement chaud dans
la tête des deux des gouvernants leur
conception de la démocratie et moi je
pense que cette crise révèle une crise
de régime en fait derrière la crise
sanitaire est là la réalité on a un
système qui a fonctionné très bien au
moment du général de gaulle avec des
grands commis de l'état qui était
efficace et qui servait l'intérêt
général on voit bien que cette cette
élite là qui en était une norme est plus
une
chateaubriand direct les lésés lille est
tout aristocratie connaît trois âges
l'âge des supériorités l'âge des
privilèges et l'âge
des vanités qu'elle dégénère dans le 2e
etc elle s'éteint dans le troisième je
crois qu'on est vraiment arrivé à l'ère
des vanités et de l'extinction et qu'il
faut changer de système et encore une
fois je ne mets pas tout sur le dos
peut-être de l'administration ça c'est
une précision parce qu' il appartient je
vois où emmanuel macron qui se plaint
dans le jdt de ne pas être obéi
enfin c'est quand même là encore on est
dans une quelque chose de comique c'est
aussi à l'état de se faire au meilleur
par son administration et s'ils n'y
arrivent pas de trouver d'autres
solutions et là quand je parlais de
crise de résine le problème c'est que je
crois que les dirigeants sont ils eux
mêmes issus de ce système on nous ment
les réflexes le vocabulaire la manière
de penser c'est pour ça aussi que cela
fonctionne pas profondément
on a très peu de temps mais j'étais un
peu long c'est vous la connaissez bien
cette haute administration française
vous en êtes issu comme hainard que vous
l'avez audités comme magistrat à la cour
des comptes elle est irréformable non
mais elle a d'abord elle n'a pas
toujours aussi mal marché mais et on
paye quand même un certain nombre de
choix
d'abord le fait que l'état a fait
clairement le choix des gros bataillons
en limitant les compétences que beaucoup
des meilleurs sont partis il faut le
dire clairement
il faut dire aussi très clairement que
pour par exemple les ministères sociaux
et la santé en particulier c'est tout
les derniers de l'ena qu'on affecte au
ministère de la santé depuis un demi
siècle et on a le résultat de ce type de
choix que les médecins de santé publique
c'est la même chose c'est quand ils
savent vraiment rien faire d'autre qu'on
les met à la santé publique et on a le
résultat de ses joueurs si vous voulez
la force de prolétarisés aussi les gens
et d'exclure tous tous ceux qui essayent
de une personnalité un peu différente ou
qui essayez de réfléchir tous ceux qui
étaient prêts à prendre des risques
il ya une mécanique quand même deux
aujourd'hui une mécanique infernale qui
sanctionne toutes les personnes qui sont
un peu différentes et qui prennent des
risques donc pas ce qu'on a dit est
tristement vrai donc ce conseil de
citoyens est complètement absurde on a
l'impression que ça marchait trop bien
donc il n'y avait pas cette chose on a
déjà la haute autorité de santé
on a le pseudo conseil scientifique on a
le conseil de défense sanitaire qui n'a
aucun sens on a un ministre qui sait
plus où il est et on va rajouter 35
malheureux citoyens pour simplifier sa
et grosso modo on a trois problèmes
comme il a été dit on a un problème de
vaccins c'est un problème scientifique
qu'est ce qu'on peut homologué il faut
les homologué plus vite possible
on a un problème de production ça c'est
le problème des industriels comment on
fait pour les produits le plus vite
possible c'est pas les 35 citoyens qui
vont pouvoir le régler et ensuite on a
un problème logistique
il ya deux personnes deux types de gens
les militaires ou les gens du privé cela
ils peuvent répondre justement les
militaires continuent en parfait si vous
le voulez bien parce que c'est notre
deuxième sujet du jour la logistique
militaire elle est au service de la
guerre c'est ce que
fait l'armée française au mali depuis
2013 les débuts de l'opération barkan
les forces armées paient un tribut très
lourd
une cinquantaine de morts depuis le
début de l'opération
cinq militaires tués ces dernières
semaines dont ce week-end le sergent
yvonne une première femme morte au
combat au mali et le brigadier loïc
crise air et à chaque fois la question
revient de vont nous quitter le mali est
ce que nous n'avons pas eu trop
d'ambition en espérant régler le
problème du jihadisme dans cette région
dont on dit souvent qu'elle est grande
comme l'europe
alexandre ii vecchio je crois que c'est
pas le moment en fait de poser c'est
est-ce où il aurait peut-être fallu la
poser avant avoir un véritable débat
généralement quand on s'en va en guerre
en france
tout le monde crie cocorico et personne
ne réfléchit donc peut-être que la
question était légitime mais enfin
maintenant on y est
les gens qui ont perdu leur vie est là
savent que leur métier c'est de servir
le pays et qui peuvent part de leur vif
ou d'ailleurs en profiter pour leur
rendre hommage
je crois qu'on est dans le le temps de
l'hommage est ensuite moi je crois que
généralement quand on se lance dans un
conflit comme ça la pire des solutions
ensuite et deux de partir sans avoir eu
de résultats c'est ce qu'ont fait les
américains en irak on a vu ce que ça a
donné avec des ce qu'on a fait nous en
libye on a eu le cas où est la crise
migratoire derrière donc maintenant
qu'on y est je pense qu'on doit y rester
c'est le moment aussi où on doit
réfléchir à ce que doit être notre
défense en europe et à ce qu'il y ait
une véritable solidarité européenne je
ne crois pas à l'europe de la défense je
crois que c'est pas une solution
réaliste que le tank qui voit le jour
voilà le le conflit au mali sera sera
terminée mais par contre réfléchir aux
moyens de
de donner justement davantage de moyens
à l'armée française qui est la
principale européenne
ça me paraît être quelque chose
d'intéressant de même peut-être
réfléchir avec les britanniques qui sont
les seuls finalement en europe avec nous
à avoir une véritable armée un système
de coopération
ils sont sortis d'une union européenne
mais ils appartiennent bien sûr toujours
à la civilisation européenne ce sont nos
alliés c'est peut-être avec lui qu'il
faut travailler et l'accord de défense
franco britannique était d'ailleurs pas
remis en cause par le départ de ce pays
de l'union européenne nicolas baverez ce
qui est ce qu'il faut partir alors
d'abord il faut rendre hommage aux
soldats français
ils sont 5000 et y tiennent une zone qui
représente 10 fois l'europe et ils ont
infligé des pertes extrêmement sévère ou
aux groupes jihadistes cela dit il faut
toujours se poser la question de
l'engagement pourquoi parce que le
problème c'est il ya deux problèmes
est ce que la france défend des intérêts
stratégiques importants et par ailleurs
est-ce qu'on a un espoir de sortie de ce
conflit qui ne peut être qu'une sortie
politique puisque le l'instrument
militaire est un instrument il doit
permettre de faire une sortie politique
et je pense que sur ces deux questions
aujourd'hui il ya des questions le
maintenant des problèmes lourds qui se
pose et je crois que la france devra de
toute manière remettre en cause cet
engagement pourquoi d'abord parce que
même si on a des succès tactique
aujourd'hui il faut être clair c'est une
défaite stratégique
si on regarde le djihadisme ans en
afrique qui progresse donc sur le sahel
on maîtrise à peu près ce qui se passe
mais aujourd'hui la pousser vers la côte
d'ivoire vers l'afrique de l'ouest vers
le col de golf de guider est plutôt en
train de s'accélérer
donc on a des succès tactique mais pas
du tout
victoire stratégique la deuxième chose
c'est que maintenant on a quand même une
junte au pouvoir au mali donc ça pose
quand même la question a donné un coup
d'état après un coup d'état et que en
plus cette gente elles discutent
ouvertement avec les groupes jihadistes
et c'est comme ça qu'il ya eu une
première libération y compris d'ailleurs
de djihadistes qui avaient tué des des
soldats français
donc est ce qu'on continue avec quand
même soutenir ce gouvernement dans ces
conditions
troisième question on est quand même
tout seul en europe et on a beau dire et
beau faire
personne ne nous aide réellement on peut
dire que les autres sont négligents on
peut peut-être se dire que s'ils n'y
vont pas c'est peut-être aussi qu'ils
ont un certain nombre de bonnes raisons
et surtout je rejoins ce qui était dit
c'est que on a une une question quand
même très lourdes c'est finalement avec
le mali et ces opex qui coûte quand même
un milliard 3 par an par ailleurs on a
une armée de corps expéditionnaire mais
on a de moins en moins une armée qui est
capable de faire face à un conflit de
haute intensité en europe face à deux
adversaires quand même très compliqué
qui manie les stratégies hybride qui
sont la russie et la turquie avec
notamment la poussée très forte de la
turquie en méditerranée est à nos portes
donc comme on ne peut pas tout faire il
ya une vraie question qui se pose est ce
que vraiment toute l'énergie l'argent
les le capital humain le capital
militaire qu'on use au mali dans ces
conditions là est-ce qu'il est encore
bien utilisé étant entendu que on n'a
aucune perspective de sortie politique
de ce conflit pour l'instant donc je
crois que ça ne remet absolument pas en
cause l'hommage que nous devons aux
femmes et aux hommes qui se battent et
qui meurent au mali mais que la question
de cet engagement
elle mérite d'être posée d'ailleurs je
vois le chef d'état-major des armées
lui-même s'inscrit très clairement dans
une logique de dans une logique de
retrait donc nous devons quand même
réfléchir à ces opex c'est à dire est ce
qu on pressent qu'on défend vraiment des
intérêts vitaux
est-ce qu'on a un mandat clair est-ce
qu'on combat avec des gens à peu près
responsables et surtout est-ce qu'on a
une sortie politique aujourd'hui sur ces
quatre questions
on a deux gros point d'interrogation au
mali récemment vous fait réagir à ces
arguments en les complétant par
eux ceux de notre confrère jean
dominique merchet qui était un grand
spécialiste des questions de défense qui
dans l'opinion de ce matin dit oui il
faut partir du mali et les façons dit il
c'est inéluctable nous quitterons le
mali nous partirons du mali comme nous
l'avons fait d'afghanistan après la mort
de 90 militaires comme les américains le
font à leur tour
sous-entendu le l'islamisme militaire le
djihadisme est un mouvement trop trop
fort dans beaucoup d'endroits du monde
pour que nous puissions le contenir à
nous seuls c'est peut-être un constat
réaliste moi je parlais surtout du
timing il me semble c'est pas quand on a
des pertes qu'il faut réfléchir à partir
et encore une fois sans doute fallait-il
y réfléchir avant tenir compte des des
leçons du passé puisque effectivement à
chaque fois qu'on a fait des guerres
justement contre le gia lis parfois même
quand il y avait pas de menace
djihadiste pensa à l'irak de saddam
hussein effectivement on se retrouve
dans cette situation là où finalement on
ne fait qu'accroître la menace
maintenant je pense que quand on est
engagé il faut quand même essayer de
sortir le moins mal possible et au moins
de sortir avec un mali - djihadistes
qu'il ne l'était au départ s'il
s'avérait qu'on partait avec avec
finalement une victoire des djihadistes
froid qu'il faudrait vraiment c'est sous
coucy entretenir la leçon pour la suite
est ce ce rêve voilà dramatique et il
faudra dire que ça a été une erreur
dramatique d'aller se lancer sur ce
terrain d'opération
les internautes qui réagissent en même
temps qu'il vous écoute sur lefigaro.fr
sur le hashtag point de vue ou sur
youtube effectivement sont assez
négatif eux kriss kross nous dit oui il
faut partir du mali
nous n'avons plus les moyens financiers
de ces opérations extérieures
nicole 0,6 on s'enlise au mali comme les
etats unis se sont enlisées en
afghanistan et pour quels résultats pour
l'interrogation
et puis chardons bleus qui considère que
nous ne sommes plus une grande puissance
mais justement nicolas baverez ça c'est
peut-être un argument qui plaide en
faveur de notre maintien
nous ne sommes peut-être plus une
puissance mondiale mais nous sommes une
puissance d' influence régionale en
particulier en afrique ne serait ce que
pour des raisons historiques
est-ce que être présents militairement
ce n'est pas un des moyens de maintenir
la présence française et l' influence
française sur ce continent
alors ça on sait que non puisque la
france est le seul pays européen qui
effectivement s'est engagé régulièrement
militairement en afrique et la france
est le pays dont les positions
économiques ont le plus reculé en
afrique
l'allemagne qui n'intervient pas à
beaucoup plus progressé en afrique est
évidemment le premier partenaire de
l'afrique aujourd'hui c'est très
largement la chine
donc on n'a jamais réussi mais
d'ailleurs ça a été la même chose dans
les balkans la france n'a jamais réussi
à convertir sa présence militaire en
suite en contrat ou en marché la
question de la puissance je la trouve
très bonne c'est vrai que quand on
regarde le déclassement de notre pays il
ya un un point fort qui reste c'est pour
ça que la france bizarrement ressemble
un peu parce que côté à la russie c'est
que notre armée est sans doute à des
derniers pôle d'excellence qui nous qui
nous reste en tout cas dans l'est dans
les services publics elle est peut-être
grâce à sa notamment parce que elle fait
la guerre et que donc elle est au
meilleur de sa performance
oui le problème si vous regardez
l'histoire militaire on a fait la guerre
on avait une armée de corps
expéditionnaire sous napoléon iii
on a fait la guerre au mexique très
courageusement dans des conditions
absurdes et on a perdu
spectaculairement
des plus grands désastres est 1870 parce
qu'on avait une armée de corps
expéditionnaire qui étaient en afrique
du nord et au mexique et on n'a pas
préparé la seule guerre qui allait
vraiment content et qui était la guerre
contre l'allemagne
et donc oui il faut faire la guerre mais
la guerre qu'on fait au mali
c'est une guerre très particulière c'est
une guerre asymétrique c'est pas du tout
une guerre de haute intensité comme
peut-être et il faut souhaiter que non
évidemment mais quand on regarde ce que
fait aujourd'hui la turquie en
méditerranée on peut se retrouver dans
des configurations qui n'ont rien à voir
et regarder ce que les projections 2d
projection de force de la turquie ou de
la russie
en syrie en libye ou haut-karabakh
c'est des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
vous mettez ce risque pour la france au
même niveau
celui de la turque et celui de la rue si
vous considérez que ces deux pays ont la
même agressivité vis-à-vis de nous nous
européens de l'ouest
ba aujourd'hui que fan la turquie quand
on regarde la turquie c'est une évidence
mais la russie c'est plus surprenant bat
la russie est quand même une
intervention militaire avérée en ukraine
regardez la suède la suède réarme et la
suède a rétabli le service militaire on
peut pas dire que les suédois soit des
gens qui sont obsédés par le fait de
guerroyer
les suédois réarme et ont rétabli
service militaire pour faire face aux
incursions
si vous regardez les activités
militaires russes dans la baltique
c'est spectaculaire et d'ailleurs c'est
le seul vrai facteur de puissance qui
reste à la russie mais qui table
vraiment là-dessus donc si vous voulez
l'activité militaire de la russie des
états baltes jusqu'à la limite elle et
elle est très spectaculaire
alors là encore ça veut dire qu'il faut
avoir des stratégies vis-à-vis de la
russie ça n'empêche pas de coopérer avec
la russie sur certains dans certains
domaines par exemple la lutte contre le
djihadisme
mais il faut regarder et à linverse il
faut être extrêmement ferme sur ce que
la nature sur ce que la russie peut
faire en baltique ou ou en ukraine je
connais et pour la turquie
franchement par exemple il faut
absolument qu'on reconstitue une marine
qui
marine de haute mer qui tiennent
aujourd'hui il n'y a pratiquement plus
de régates
on n'a pas deux patrouilleurs s'il y
avait un problème majeur en afrique du
nord
il faut vraiment s'y remettre et à mon
avis est beaucoup plus prioritaire que
d'aller
s'éterniser au mali dans les conditions
un dernier mot sur cet argument
concentrer nos forces en europe
ça vous chante abonnement je pense qu'il
va falloir réinvestir réarmer
globalement en europe je pense
qu'effectivement la menace turque est
une menace réelle apparaît simplement
beaucoup plus importante que la menace
russe
j'ajoute que les turcs font partie de
l'otan ce qui est quand même assez
paradoxal je pense que en plus bladimir
routine veut faire la russie veut faire
partie de la civilisation occidentale et
qu'il ya des marges de négociation qu'il
n'ya pas avec erdogan et je pense que
décorrélée la question du jihadisme en
afrique et d'erdogan est pas forcément
la même chose que c'est aussi
l'islamisme et aussi me menace globale
et plus le janice progresse jusqu'au
confort du mag a peut-être demain en
algérie où la situation est instable ça
risque aussi de menacer directement
l'europe donc je sais pas si la situer
là la réponse est directement militaire
maintenant mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il faut s'en préoccuper et réhab
merci beaucoup monsieur merci à tous les
deux merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et ce sera un plaisir de vous retrouver
demain pour une nouvelle édition de
points 2
[Musique]